good evening everybody my name is
shannon rose mcauliffe and i'm glad to
welcome you here to another 15k creative
arts competition workshop
this evening we're going to be focusing
on for-profit ventures and business
plans with carly chase
i'm joined by theo fields say hello theo
hi everyone um and you know
we've got some conversation that we're
gonna have carly's gonna share
a lot of her wealth of intelligence with
us we'll have some q a so
um you know without further ado carly do
you want to do a quick introduction and
then launch it right in
absolutely yeah that is part of part of
my
perfect um so let me just share my
slides
and i know that this is being recorded
and i assume will be heard by others
potentially but um just so we give
those of us who are on the call the most
benefit um
diana and cida tell me if i just
pronounced your name wrong or if i
completely butchered it
um is it cider or ceta cedar no
theta okay i took a 50 50 chance and i
of course was on the wrong side of that
um i want to make sure this is as useful
for you guys as possible so
um you know if you want to give me any
context about what you're working on
so i can sort of tailor this to that and
then we can sort of talk through
specific things
in regards to your own businesses um i
would love to do that if you guys just
want to sit back and listen
no pressure um so
maybe i can't see your faces and that's
totally fine but um
do you guys want to talk about your
business do you want not talk about your
business maybe just give me an idea
before we jump in
sure i'm happy to to give you my
30-second pitch but i also recognize
other folks my view this video later so
definitely don't tailor everything to
um to our ideas um so i'm
working on an idea that so far i'm
calling fused exact name tbd
um and also going to be part of the the
sorry
muse it's going to be part of the fuse
program
awesome thank you so i'm excited to work
on it over iap
and the idea the need that i'm trying to
solve is that art supplies today is
really really expensive and primarily
purchased through
brick and mortar stores um and there's
no good places online to buy anything
and
for artists who are aspiring to do stuff
for aspiring artists it's actually
really hard to get started
um so my idea right now is to create a
digitally native
uh art supply purchasing experience that
can help aspiring artists get started
that's awesome cool and do you have a
team that you're working on this one i
don't have a team unfortunately but i
am looking for it this is going to be
tailored actually well to you then
so this is perfect um and diana do you
want to give us a shout or are you just
going to
hang with us uh
well i i just uh
[Music]
i knew few things about this program
but i my intention is to learn more
something that can help me in the future
because i want to be a
an act of the mit
art culture and technology candidate for
a master
cool that's why i wanted to know
more and be more involved in in the
programs that mit have
so awesome good all right cool okay
so we'll get started then um so my name
is carly
um i think that whenever you're
listening to a presentation you should
get context for where
all of this is coming from um there's no
hard and fast rules in entrepreneurship
and there is no single framework
so therefore everything in my opinion is
an opinion that you're going to hear
from anybody in entrepreneurship it's
just based on their own experiences
and the range of experiences of
entrepreneurs is really vast
and so the conte the context um and
and to basically contextualize what i'm
going to tell you today of course is
based on my own experience
so i want to give you sort of the full
the full context on me
so um i started my career goldman sachs
and finance um i lived through the 2008
financial crisis there
stayed a number of years after that and
then decided that
um you know the corporate world which i
thought was going to be my entire career
that i was going to
try something else on that maybe this
wasn't going to be the the most fun
place for the rest of my career
and decided to go join the local
government in new york city where i
actually
live and still live today i'm in
brooklyn right now um
so i worked for mayor michael
bloomberg's administration
um in economic development and back then
this was about eight years ago
new york was trying to figure out how to
compete after the the financial crisis
how to diversify our economy and one way
was to
bring more startups to new york so we
were trying to figure out how do we
compete with san francisco and london
and boston
um and make new york more attractive for
founders
the arts was a huge obviously existing
industry in new york for instance so we
said you know what are the assets that
we already have
you know and how can we get more
entrepreneurs to feel confident that new
york is a great place to not only start
but be able to grow their business
so i worked with a lot of founders um
sort of figured out what the perceived
and
um and real uh challenges were with
coming to new york and that's really how
i sort of got my startup bug
so then i uh decided to really try
out startups um and was hired as the
general manager of a real estate tech
startup another
industry obviously that's enormous in
new york real estate
um and basically was the founder of the
new york office for
a real estate marketplace called
pivotdesk i did that for a number of
years until we were
sold to a national co-working provider
called industrious
and then since have been within either a
full-time or consulting capacity and now
i advise a couple of early stage
startups
a number of venture-backed startups and
also have my own
non-venture back startup which is
another option for people uh who are
starting their own business you don't
always have to do the full
venture-backed
crazy accelerated growth business model
called crabwalk which is all about
helping people
get ownership over their careers and
this new i'd say way of work where
um you know i thought like i already
mentioned i was at goldman sachs i
thought i was gonna be there and go up a
ladder there is no ladder anymore so
people need a lot more help in
navigating their careers
and in between that all i found myself
here at mit where i am
have been for about three and a half
years an entrepreneur in residence at
the trust center
um running a number of our
extracurricular programs including our
accelerator program
delta v and our intro to
entrepreneurship bootcamp start mit
i also um i'm a senior lecturer for two
classes and
as an eir get to coach a bunch of
students which is
a ton of fun so since we're going to be
talking about business plans
i will tell you that i've seen i've had
the privilege of seeing so many business
plans at this point
both from early in my career and now of
course at mit talking to
lots of different students who work on
lots of different industries and
problems and
you know if you guys uh could sort of
tell me
or uh for anybody who wants to respond
i'm just sort of curious what you hear
by a business plan because i feel like
this is a really big topic there's
business plan competitions there's
business plan submissions
there's financial projections i'm just
sort of curious any perceptions that
people have about
like what is this business plan thing
anyways
i can share what what i i tend to think
of it as
yeah um it's your go forward plan for
how
um you intend to make revenue through
what streams
um how you intend to be a viable
business
and not only viable at point of launch
but also sustainable going forward
yeah i really like that so so i agree
that a lot of business plans are
um when i think of business plan i also
like put it in
adjacent to money and i put it adjacent
to profits and profitability
and the thing about a business is that
is the ultimate goal you do not have a
business unless you have paying
customers that is a core role of ours at
the trust center
but i really think about the business
plan as helpful in a lot of ways and so
that's really right that's kind of the
end goal
and and what what cedar really hit on
the head is
we need we need a direction right like a
lot of times in entrepreneurship things
are going so fast and you just want to
you know
get to the next goal and the next
milestone and the next milestone but
if you don't actually have a direction
if you don't know where you're going in
the long run
you're gonna miss a lot of stuff right
and you're gonna you're gonna sort of
um your vision will probably actually
narrow down smaller to what it really
could be if you took a moment to sort of
look around and understand um the full
picture and
and set a direction yourself so i really
love this quote
um that brad feld who's a actually
happens to be an mit grad and as a
really prominent and famous venture
capitalist that i have a lot of respect
for
um and he says it's a critical document
for an entrepreneur to organize their
thoughts around their new business
um and this is what i think is really
critical so if i think um
ceta you really hit the nail on the head
in terms of what the ultimate goal is it
is to
to get revenue and to create a
sustainable business um because without
customers and revenue
there is no sustainable business um but
i really think and i really love this
phrasing that a business plan is an
opportunity for you to really organize
your thoughts
and to me one of the biggest goals um or
what
or reasons why you'd want to organize
your thoughts is so you can communicate
them
because really your job as an
entrepreneur at the end of the day is to
set a vision and communicate your vision
right that's you can raise money from
investors it's so you can find teammates
and
and build you know have co-founders and
eventually employees and so you can talk
to partners and customers
really having a way to organize your
thoughts so you can communicate them out
is really really key and and frankly
it's something that i really see as
undervalued in most entrepreneurs they
just sort of think you know the product
is the important thing to refine and
i'll just sort of wing
my messaging or the way i pitch um and
that is really
i would almost say the opposite right uh
product good product is a
it's a must-have you don't really have a
business if you don't have something
exciting to sell
but if you can't communicate that out it
really doesn't matter in the first place
and just piggybacking off of that yeah
that's one of the elemental
aspects of the 15k specifically i think
that
it's necessary to have sort of bedrock
business fundamentals but especially in
the
arts we don't have as many quantitative
measures to sort of be able to convey in
a slide
and i think that while pitches are
really important i think that we
really emphasize and value a really
clear communicative
persuasive and engaging pitch maybe
above other
almost anything else yeah totally
and so um you know these are a few
reasons that i sort of came up
to sort of give you a whole set of
reasons
as to why you do a business plan but i
would actually sort of
move your eyes to the the third one in
the middle of this slide
because this is really how i think about
a business plan it's like this master
document you have
that helps you it's your business plan
this version of your business plan at
least you're going to have lots of
versions of your business plan depending
on who the audience is
and we can talk about sort of what the
different audiences um you'll need it
for i just mentioned a few
but think of this plan that i'm talking
about today as like your master document
that's an internal document that's just
for you
it's a living document that you're going
to update all the time and
iterate on so that you can you can pull
from it when you're talking to a
specific
audience so you know okay here's my
master plan it has
you know 15 different sections when i'm
talking to
an investor versus a customer i'm going
to need to pull different sections and
insights from it right not everybody
should see everything about your
business and you should be really
thoughtful and you'll learn how to do
that over time about what to share
and and frankly what not to share um and
that's that's a whole other different
communication skill set um that we could
talk about at a different time
um and so i would argue i think a lot of
business plans
are we talked about in powerpoint or
even excel when you think about sort of
like financial projections
i would argue unless you love powerpoint
and some people do
i personally don't this is even keynote
a version of a
better version of powerpoint in my
opinion that i use today but i really
like text especially when we're talking
communication
i think it's so important to be able to
write succinctly
and compellingly in text right because
that's how we communicate
we talk on the phone we write emails um
we write proposals and powerpoint is one
way to communicate but in my
in my head it's not the world's best way
to sort of
um get out all of your thoughts it could
be like sort of a high level version of
your thoughts and you can take that
master text and translate it into
powerpoint for different audiences but
um again my two cents my my personal
opinion my personal experience um
i don't necessarily think powerpoint is
the way to
communicate your business plan um
so again we talked about this a little
before but who is a business plan for
um i just put a scenario out here and um
for for ceta you could even say just one
co-founder now
you know say your two co-founders you
started working together in september at
the beginning of the school year
and you want to recruit other team
members and enter competitions soon
you know maybe you've done some primary
market research you've begun to
prototype
so you know we need a master document so
you know we're two co-founders or i'm
one person that works by
myself or you know maybe i'm uh you know
a typical scenario as as somebody um you
know maybe like a professor or a pi
and and two students uh working to
commercialize research
and you know what this document can do
for you as co-founders or team members
or for a single person who's working on
their business
this is just an opportunity to coalesce
your thoughts
and to to write down everything that's
happening today right it's just a
it's it's a what's happened up to now
document and where do i want to go from
here
um and again you're going to iterate
this and iterate and iterate
and refine it depending on the audience
you're talking to but
um you know this is almost one of the
first things you should do in your
business in my
opinion because especially when you have
multiple people involved uh
this is also a great document if you do
have a co-founder or you do have team
members
to also make sure you guys are on the
same page right it's really easy to sort
of assume that you're going in the same
direction but
you know if you don't actually check in
and confirm that you could easily be
diverging
and so the earlier in your venture you
can do this the more aligned you're
going to be in the long run
so when we think about what should be in
my business plan and this is going to be
a really long um slide that we can talk
to and and we can sort of
talk to whatever people want to talk
about but you know these are suggestions
right these are what i've seen in
business plans and you might be able
to fill in all of these sections today
and you might not be able to right and i
think
as much as um you need to sort of
understand and comprehend
what you currently have it's also an
opportunity to figure out what don't i
have what haven't i thought about or
what haven't i figured out yet or
you know what am i less confident in and
again
right the benefit of putting this in
text is you can also use this document
to get feedback
one thing that entrepreneurs need to be
good at is
asking for help right and so not only
asking for help like
you know i'm really bad at creating a
vision that's something that scares me
i'm really good at sort of staying in
the
near term what i want but what is that
really what could that be in the long
term
or you know i'm less great at
understanding unit economics can i get
some feedback on this
you know this business plan hopefully
empowers you to go and get the advice
and um and the support you need and and
also to be able to check in and say you
know this makes sense to me does this
make sense to somebody else and that
sort of
overarching goal of communication um and
again this is just a list of suggestions
that you should absolutely
um customize to your business and your
stage of business um
you know if you're if you're that
scenario that i just put
before this it's probably pretty hard to
have financial projections at this point
and that's totally okay just leave that
open
and and know that every time you get a
clue for that section just
add it add it back in um okay
so just to sort of go through these
really quick i'm just gonna
switch where my zoom is so i can see
every single bullet um so starting with
your mission statement
so and your vision statement and i think
there's a big question sometimes about
the difference between these two
to me a vision is really the direction
you want to go in long term
you know maybe it's not has nothing to
do with the the way you're going to go
to market or your first customer it's
really how do i see this business having
impact in the long run um you know what
is the ultimate goal of this business
and the mission statement is really
close to that but that's almost you know
why am i doing this or why are we doing
this as a team
you know why is this important in the
world or in my industry or to my
customer
um so vision where the direction you
want to go and mission i would say why
why this is important um the next
most important thing what is the problem
you're solving
so so important to be able to succinctly
state this is actually sometimes one of
the hardest things
to do because you know you start with um
a problem
and then you and then you decide to go
talk to a bunch of customers
and then you sort of pivot to you know
to from where you started to more of
what you're hearing in the customers and
back again
a lot of times um you know all of the
different customer research we do
and and market research we do um creates
like amaze in our heads as entrepreneurs
i don't know if that's making sense and
resonating with folks it typically does
when i'm
when i'm teaching to my students um and
uh
and again taking an opportunity to
really try to
write out the problem you're solving it
might sound trivial but it's actually
in my opinion one of the hardest parts
of the business plan
um then you want to talk about all of
the market research you've done
so you know i've talked to these many
customers
our prospective customers i've talked
you know i've researched the market
landscape i understand the history of
the problem i'm trying to solve
i understand the context i'm trying to
operate in i understand
you know those who are currently trying
to solve this problem
here's who's tried it in the past and
why they failed um
and then you go on to you know your
solution here is the solution to the
problem i'm solving here
is you know if it's a if it's a product
that you've prototyped so far or have
product specs or a product brochure
you can put that in here is the way i'm
going to develop this product over time
you know that'll get to eventually the
resources that you need to
create this company um and then you know
here's how i'm actually going to put
this into market
this is how i'm gonna to get started you
know here's the the first customer i
started with if you guys are familiar
with the concepts
um of beachhead market and persona um
you know who is my primary customer and
how am i gonna reach them
am i going to do traditional you know is
it a consumer product do i have to do
traditional digital marketing
is it a b2b product am i going to have a
direct sales process
is it a medical device am i going to
have licensing agreements with
existing distribution partners um you
know what's what's your idea for how you
how you get started here and um and then
of course i think
i know that shannon said you guys are
going to have a workshop on value
propositions i think another
such an important piece of communication
for your
business really to understand the value
that you're delivering
especially for this primary customer um
and then eventually i think
i do think you know business model unit
economics financial projections
um those probably come a little bit
later
just because you do need some
information to really understand the
world you're operating in
you might have some initial assumptions
that is great to include
um and then the team the team is is a
really important part of your business
plan you know who is working on this
what are your skill sets what is your
existing experience
why are you interested in this um and
perhaps you might even have a couple of
blank people
right things you need people you need to
find or skill sets you need to acquire
um so again it can be you know your
existing business plan especially when
you're really early stage
because this can really serve as an
internal document for you
it can be here's all the things we've
done and here's all the sections and and
questions that we still need to fill out
and answer
and then finally what this really helps
you do is figure out you know what
resources do i have and what resources
do i need
and so if you've actually mapped all of
this out and this is a lot of work on a
single slide i'm not trying to diminish
the level of work that this
is to to create and and write something
like this then you can say okay here are
the resources i need
here's the type of financing that i need
to get this off the ground here's the
team i need to create
maybe you have a section of even here's
advisors i'd love to have
here are um
uh here are you know random whatever the
resource sort of plan that you need
financing is just one of those types of
resource um people are another really
important type of resource
um so so this is really hopefully
a entire um sort of memo to yourself to
say
you know here's where i am today and
here's what i need going forward
so i know that i just said a lot so i
just want to take a minute in case
there's any questions or
or if anybody wants to sort of ask
specific questions about their situation
that was a really good overview i think
and um
you know you hit on a lot of the things
especially sort of almost doing like
a gap analysis like here's what we've
got here's where we want to be in sort
of reverse engineering
what is it we need who is it that we
need it really helps everybody to gain
some clarity about that
so i really think that was great
perfect i have i have two questions of
that
one specific to the creative arts
competition so i think a lot of
our ideas are pretty um early stage
what's the expectation that we'll have
unit economics and financial projections
for the competition
we like to see that this sort of has had
some due diligence and some
consideration we're looking for real
viability but
you also don't have to hand us like a
perfect comprehensive 10-year plan
anything like that so
if you use these sorts of workshops
we'll also make some other resources
available we'd like to see something at
least
preliminary um and in the second part of
the competition there's a lot of
one-on-one mentorship
with people and when you apply you can
also indicate like we need help with
marketing or we need help with our slide
deck we need help with a business plan
and ideally you'll be matched with a
mentor who will be able to help you
through those sorts of things
so tell you what you're doing right
strengthen any muscles that need a
little more attention so
having a basic idea and an understanding
of how this all fits into place
is really helpful and there will also be
more guidance and resources
got it okay perfect that's helpful and
my second question is
um for business plans in general carly
how often do you think we should be
evolving and updating um this document
especially if we're treating it as a
master
text yeah i think that's a great
question but i also want to just go back
to your first question too because
i think um a couple ideas for you
uh it sounds have you even started to
explore the idea of unit economics for
your business
uh no not really okay cool so january on
that yeah so fuse in particular will be
a great place
so right one way for your traditional
ecommerce business right at its heart
so i think the good part about that is
that there's some existing um tactics
whether it's you know putting up a
landing page or testing some instagram
instagram ads i don't know if you have
sandbox funding but that could be a
really good
use for that type of funding just to
sort of to test some ads and figure out
for instance
um you know there's a there's a unit
economic i don't know if you're
familiar with it called cost per click
so
so figuring out you know how many people
are clicking on my ad
you know what was the cost of that ad
and then dividing it by the number of
clicks and then
that's that's just like a starting
ground um but the other way just because
you are
in a in a world that's that's pretty
known obviously
you know you're trying to do something
different but you could definitely look
also at other
you know ecommerce or direct to consumer
businesses when you're doing some market
landscape just
to see if there's some comparables um
you know whether that's specific
businesses or sort of
expected averages um that stuff changes
all the time so you want to make sure
that that market research is reasonably
up to date
um obviously you know another um new
digital marketing channel tick tock
hasn't been around a lot but um but
there's definitely some
some interesting um and creative ways
for customer acquisition
in that front so um so those are two
ideas i think you'll have a ton
if that would be a goal of yours and
fuse i think that you could easily get a
bunch of help there doing that
and testing um just some digital ads but
um the other thing is
you know there's definitely some comps
i'm sure in the market that you could
use as a placeholder for now
um and then i think in terms of updating
i think it's a good question
so i think you know is this a document
that you might
always want to have open and updating
whenever you know you're getting sort of
an opportunity probably
but i don't know if that's realistic so
what i would say is i
think having it as like a calendar
reminder like once a month
you know or blocking it out for like two
hours just to look at it
i think is a really good thing not only
because i'm sure at the stage of
business you're at you're gonna have
lots to sort of update
but i think again it's just a good
document to help you reflect
and also help you say okay here's all
right these are basically every single
bullet point is
is a is something to figure out in your
business it's like open questions
and so if you can sort of just even use
this as a reminder
to say hey here's the 10 sort of open
questions i need to continue to figure
out how to
you know understand oh i've spent a lot
of time this month on
you know prototyping my website and um
you know doing customer
interviews but i forgot to like try that
digital ad thing it'll just help you
sort of i think stay grounded and
and be able to see the big picture so
you're not really missing anything in
the near term
does that make sense yeah totally that's
really helpful
yeah yeah um and for you this is going
to be you know i would also say the use
for you in this is
eventually when you do find a teammate
whether that's a co-founder or just a
teammate it doesn't have to be a
co-founder necessarily
um you know this is a great way to get
them on your page and help them
understand
what you've already done
um and the slide was just i think i sort
of
demonstrated that in the prior prior
slide but you know in my opinion your
business plan should really be all
encompassing
um so there might be sections that i
didn't include that that you might say
you know i want to i want to talk about
x or y
um and so feel free to add it and um
you know and to iterate it based on that
general template
um and then i do want to sort of plug
this you know this is the framework that
we use at the trust center discipline
entrepreneurship so if you want a
framework to figure out how to answer
all those questions discipline
entrepreneurship is absolutely
a great one to leverage um so the the
graphic you're seeing on the left hand
of the screen
is the 24-step framework um if you're
not familiar with discipline
entrepreneurship
i would number one say it's an
incredibly easy read it's not a
traditional business text it's
it really is not intimidating you can
read it in a weekend um
i'm not a person who loves to read a
book in a weekend but i can easily read
discipline entrepreneurship in a weekend
and
um and it really does take you step by
step and and you'll realize once you're
going through these that it becomes much
easier to answer those questions and
you know these are sort of the the the
bullet points on this slide
um are the high level points that i
think this framework is really really
useful to help you answer
and and by the way in the right order
right you want to understand who your
customer is before designing the product
for that customer for instance um
you know once you understand the
customer and the product then the
question is how is my customer gonna
find this product
um how am i gonna make money what are
the unit economics and then eventually
um you know how do i actually scale this
for impact
getting to that back to that vision um
and so really the last slide i have
again is
the benefit of doing all this work
because i know that a business
plan can be a tremendous amount of
writing and a tremendous amount of work
but it'll make a lot of things easier
right it's sort of doing
the legwork to help you be more
efficient in the long run frankly and so
communication again
is one of those things that you know it
can take you a ton of time to
to explain to an investor what's going
on in your business or
a new hire that you just met that you're
super excited about and you want to
email immediately
so hopefully um it's obvious to see the
value of just putting some real thought
into this
this business plan memo and um taking
some time to really build it out
so that you can react really really
quick to to people who you want to
communicate to
to questions that are asked of you um
you know i think about it as like a
cheat sheet
for for my business um so
that is all i have for you guys um i
hope that was helpful
and happy to stick around for questions
um
but i will also say we have a ton of of
resources on our website
entrepreneurship.mit.edu and
orbit which is has a huge knowledge base
so if you want more resources in the
meantime that's a great place to go to
thank you so much this was great it was
so straightforward
and well conceived i think this will be
really helpful
um i mean does anybody else have
questions i have a few things that came
up but
sita do you have any questions
i have a question for carly that's not
specific to business plan
so maybe yeah go for it you want to go
first okay go for it
okay so carly you mentioned that crab
walk is
a venture-backed startup so curious to
get your thoughts on
what are the considerations that we
should take into mind when deciding
whether to go down the vc
um uh financing path or or
not um and how does that affect the
day-to-day operations i feel like i have
a hunch but would love to hear your
thoughts
yeah it's a fantastic question i think
one that's probably not asked enough
especially around a campus like mit
where or venture
frankly vcs are all over campus and and
second um
you know it's it's fun to talk about
right it feels like a huge milestone to
raise
a big amount of money and um and so the
first thing i will say about that
is um i think that's the wrong attitude
i think instead of saying
congratulations when somebody raises a
round
it should be good luck because basically
what you're signing up for to
start answering your question is you
know you're signing up to return
a lot more than a lot more in capital
than you took
right you know venture is an asset class
where they don't want just two times
their money back they want like 10x
or 100x their money so you know first of
all you have to be ready to be on their
timeline
typically what they're they want you to
do is return their money so that level
of return
in five to seven years or sometimes now
more like seven to ten years time
timeline so if you want to have a hyper
growth
um you know scale for impact business
and that skill for impact is a big deal
right that's why people do want to take
venture money and they do want to become
founders a lot of time because they want
to have that impact and you really do
i mean capital is your way to get there
right to have money to to grow your
business to a scale where
um you know not only do there are the
returns great for you and the investors
but but the impact of your business is
great for your customers and society
depending on what the business is
um so so the first one thing i would say
is you have to be ready to be on that
timeline
and that hyper growth mentality and so
you know if you don't have those
fundamental questions answered
in the business plan for instance you're
probably you know you may or may not be
ready to be on that growth path
um and then i think the second thing is
um so actually so personally to me uh
my business partner uh just wasn't
interested we both came from venture
back startups she's actually a full-time
career coach in her sort of day job when
mine is at mit um and she kind of said
you know i'm really burnt out on that
type of
business building maybe we'll do that
one day but
it's it's actually not something i'm
interested in right now so she sort of
made the decision for us and i was
i was supportive of that just given sort
of um
the whole picture of our lives right now
we didn't decide to sort of do that 100
um and and so the second part of that on
the other side is
do you think your business can return
that right when you figure out those
unit economics and you figure out that
business model
like is your business going to have a
venture-backed return because there's a
lot of startups that simply aren't
and that's totally fine but you should
you know you should sort of have an idea
not in detail but but high level like
how would i even go about returning that
money and are the economics of my
business
ever going to get to a point where you
know i could be having 100 million
dollars in
revenue you know every month monthly
recurring revenue or annual recurring
revenue and if the answer is no then
that's totally fine
you know an e-commerce business direct
to consumer um
that's a business model that that has to
you know a lot of times not all the time
um but but has proven that that that can
return because you don't have
heavy assets of a brick-and-mortar store
right that's what you're sort of trying
to disrupt
um but those businesses you know there's
there's some really big successes and
then sometimes
um you know there's there's other
challenges like logistics and and that
sort of stuff so
i hope that answers your questions it
does yeah no i i really appreciate the
perspective
and i agree definitely not something we
talk about much um and i wish there was
more conversation around it
if you're at that point where you're not
quite a venture-backable business we're
not
allowed to say um but you don't quite
have enough funding
to continue going forward like what are
the different financing options
available at that point
yeah so the best source of financing
always is revenue from customers
so that's you know that's why focusing
on the customer is
early is so important to us because to
have that option even
um you know there's some great stories
from business and i'd be happy to send
you
one or two that i that i have in my mind
of um
you know companies bootstrapping until
they're
like 10 million dollars in monthly
revenues and then them saying like okay
i need you know if i want to get past
this i really need some venture capital
and right the whole idea of venture
capital is that you're you're trading
ownership in your company for money
and so if you can get to if you can get
to a crazy milestone like i'm not saying
that's easy but like if you actually
have the capacity to raise revenue from
your customers or get
you know in the medical community or the
deep science community like the
nih or um other different grant
opportunities
that is equity free money um mit there
is a lot of equity free money not
not in the millions but in the tens of
thousands for sure
um if not a hundred thousand if you were
to win you know the 100k competition
um you know the the further you can go
before taking venture money the more of
your company you'll be able to own
so if you do have that really crazy
return on the other end you can really
profit from it as opposed to just your
investors
got it
yeah i have to do is win this
competition you know that's the uh
the easiest path
uh honestly it's easier than uh than
than um
going through that whole headache of of
you know trying to raise venture and
being stuck with them this is a little
bit of pain for a short amount of time
that that's a lot a different type of
pain for a lot longer
mr i've heard a few kind of stories like
you can't
can't divorce anyone who uh invest in
your business
and so it's like the only yeah
relationship you can't get out of
um one thing that i think is interesting
is
writing a business plan is often like
kind of a clarifying
sometimes kind of transformative process
for ideas do you have any examples of
like a good kind of
before and after of an idea with going
through that business plan process
um it's like a question i don't have one
that comes to mind but i think a common
thing that happens
is people are not specific enough
like with their customer in particular
or the way they want to go to market
so you know even saying like oh you know
we're a consumer business we're gonna go
and do digital advertising like i hear
that from students all the time and i'm
like great
like tell me more about that you know
digital advertising what's you know
what's the the cost of customer
acquisition
what is you know the cost per click of
your ad what does that funnel look like
and so i think that the transformation
that typically happens
is you you think you have a level of
specific specificity that's enough
but um in reality when you actually go
to write it out
or go to try to communicate to somebody
that that sort of
is in a position to give you real
feedback it's not nearly specific enough
so i think it really helps you narrow in
i think that's really good advice
especially since we have such a heavy
mentorship
component in this competition and if
people want to take the most advantage
maximize their time with people
having greater specificity to then get
sort of feedback on that
is a lot better than taking someone's
time as they walk you through that
process
um i mean wherever you are it's great if
you need help finding that specificity
we're here but if you have the capacity
for that ahead of time
you can really maximize the mentorship
opportunities
yeah and i would just add to that i
think that's totally right shannon and
you know people especially mentors they
want to like brainstorm with you right
they want to like actually
help you and they can't help you if
you're just having if the whole
conversation's about just getting you to
explain what you're doing
if you actually present them with like
you know i tested this you know a versus
b
and this is what happened then they're
going to be like oh that's such a great
test and
oh you know tell me what you learned and
here's some you know here's five other
ideas of other things you can test
as opposed to you just starting to say
like oh i'm gonna you know i'm gonna
have a digital marketing you know i saw
the industry
averages you know 15 you know cost per
click and it's like okay great that
doesn't really tell me anything specific
it doesn't give me an idea of your
thought process as an entrepreneur
or executor it's just you know you've
done some basic market research and have
some basic assumptions but
you know to really go the extra mile and
hopefully your business plan can sort of
reveal
when you need to do that um will really
help you have much more productive
conversations
and and utilize the resources of this
competition and and the other resources
around mit a little bit better
so in that same vein um like what
happens if you change your mind
what happens if you need to evolve your
idea uh what happens if you're not
growing or if you sort of miscalculated
your risks like how do you change your
existing
infrastructure especially in response to
either failure or
constructive criticism from a mentor or
whatever it might be
yeah so um that obviously gets more more
difficult over time
but it's never too late um i will use
the big tech story of last week to give
everybody an example so slack
which just sold to salesforce for 26
billion dollars um
was a video game application and i think
i don't
i don't know the number off the top of
my head of venture capital that they
burned but they were a full-fledged
company and and by the way stuart
um butterfield who's the ceo this was
the second rodeo so it's not like he
wasn't
experienced as an entrepreneur and an
executor
he had built flickr before which i
believe was a different pivot i don't
know if you guys are
old enough to remember um flickr which
was a photo app
that sold to yahoo um it was one of the
original photo apps um
and uh and and he made a second pivot
with slack it was literally a video game
app
um slack was a chat i think an internal
messaging tool that they used and then
they decided to
um get all their investors together tell
them
you know he wasn't gonna return their
money he was gonna reinvest the money in
this new business and he hoped that they
were on board i can't remember if he
gave people an opportunity to buy out or
not
at that point um and and obviously that
was a great success
um that's extreme i'm not i'm not saying
that's your pivot but
um you know i think i think to try to
answer your question more literally and
more
um uh something that people can actually
uh take away from it is um you know you
need to
the first thing is you need to sort of
figure out again the specific things you
want to change
and you need to be able to communicate
that so i think the most important thing
and what i'm sure um
you know stuart did right was that he
was able to communicate exactly
why what he was doing wasn't working
anymore
and where he was going he had a new
vision he had a new mission statement he
had a new business plan
um and so you know i'm sure what he was
able to do is very effectively
communicate that not only to his
investors
we needed to in theory get on board um
to his board members so i'm sure had to
approve the pivot
and then to his employees who he was
going to change the entire
purpose of of their job and they were no
longer working at a gaming company which
is
certainly i think a specific type of
culture of a startup to
you know an enterprise chat solution
which is a really different type of
company to build
so um you know i don't think i don't
think anybody should ever be scared of
pivoting i think
um you know i get i get students who
you know four or five months into their
venture they say you know
this isn't working and then they sort of
just keep bumping against it but they're
too scared and it's like well i already
put this much time into my business
it's like there's so much more time
hopefully on the other side of this
decision right so so whatever you know i
think one of the most frustrating parts
about entrepreneurship
is that it's not efficient and like the
sunken costs
are something that's really hard for us
to let go of
and i think that's actually one of the
most important sort of
muscles that you can build in early
stage startups is learning how to be
okay with saying goodbye to your sunken
class
with being saying goodbye to the time
you just wasted trying a bunch of stuff
that didn't work
work and um it's it's that analogy
i don't have a better analogy than this
but it's what people say when you have a
baby you forget all the pain and
you know a minute after you see like
your child's face for the first time
it's the same thing like you could i
have students who you know they've made
a
10 pivots i run delta v in new york we
pivot all summer sometimes for
for teams i had um a team in 2018 called
roon they
started as um a customer service app
they were they had
natural language processing and so they
decided they came into delta v they
pitched me on this awesome
idea i was super excited about helping
to train customer service agents a lot
more
fast and efficiently and um they pivoted
for two months into the program and
didn't land on their existing idea until
like
august 5th delta v is a three-month
program and ends like
august 30th and you know that was really
well worth
it they they did such an amazing job and
uh
two and a half years later they went
through yc
they raised two million dollars and
they're still in business in san
francisco so even though
you know they might have felt like they
had at that point like six months of
sunken costs
it was it was an unbelievable um
reflection on them as entrepreneurs to
see that they were willing to pivot
you know and this is a most comfortable
environment like they had board meetings
they had to go to they had mentors they
were telling what you know they did all
summer and
um and they just stood there proudly and
said you know we're pivoting what can we
say we're gonna we're not gonna nail it
until
we're not gonna do this until we're
super excited about what we're doing and
um
it really paid off and i have a lot of
those stories too
that is really that's uh you got to have
a little bit of
maybe nerve to pivot late in the process
like that but i think that's a great
point and i think that the slack example
is really poignant
um this has been a great you know an
hour is definitely not enough time
and there's so much to talk about with
entrepreneurship but if you have kind of
one
one takeaway or one probe wisdom to
share with folks who are looking to
compete in this creative arts
competition
or entrepreneurship competitions more
broadly uh what would that kind of
key takeaway or probably jumpy yeah i'm
uh
i'm gonna sound like a broken record but
it's really your ability to communicate
is the most important thing you can have
the coolest idea in the world the
coolest product but if you cannot
communicate that to others and they
you can't get people excited about it or
ultimately buy your product
it doesn't matter like there's so many
cool technologies that never got off the
ground
or cool technologies that you know where
the inventor didn't end up getting
credit because they weren't the ones to
commercialize it right like the um
the mp3 being like one of the best
examples in history
um and and so you know not only should
you
focus on communication and it shouldn't
be a second thought it really should be
one of your primary
focuses just like you know technology
and product development is for so many
of us at mit
um you know practicing communication is
just
the most important thing um and not only
for this competition that i know
but um but really in the long run and
and figuring out
not only what you're going to say but
how you're going to deliver it um
equally important
i have a question sure um
would we what would be your opinion
i mean um is there any an important
difference between
our focused businesses and
other type of businesses such as
technology focus ones
and the other question would be
uh what would be the key challenges for
for art projects and how can we
[ __ ] uh can we
face them yeah that's a great question
so so the first thing i will say is that
i think um
creative arts businesses can be
technology
um businesses so so they can be two
different things but they
you know i think for the purpose
especially this competition they they're
you know one in the same or they need to
be combined
and then you know i think frankly one of
the challenges with with this sector
overall
is that in a way there's so much
opportunity because there's been so many
business models and arts that have been
really
challenged you know since since the
internet really right when you think
about music in particular
i mean one of my first things i was
thinking about when you answered that
question is
you know the the size of the market
sometimes isn't
as big an arts as it is in other
industries but then i think about
spotify and
in the music market and um i was just
listening to somebody talk about this
and i think it was kara swisher who i'm
a huge fan of she's a technology
reporter
and um she was talking about how and no
other medium has has there been such an
elegant solution to have
every single song in the world like you
can't have every tv show on a single app
right now you can't
you know i guess you can sort of have
every book but um with audible or and
some other i don't even know what the
book apps are but um but
you know you know spotify was like such
a feat
but but it's difficult right and and i
think
creative arts like every other industry
is is getting eaten by the really big
tech giants and so right everybody now
is trying to play in music
apple amazon um
google and you know it's um
it's it's a really interesting time i
think to be in creative arts i think
even now with covid right and
you see all the theater art artists in
particular having to completely rethink
the entire way that they do things
um you know i think i think there's a
lot of challenge
in this in this sort of area in this
industry and and in a way that's kind of
the most exciting thing for
entrepreneurs to to sort of see all the
opportunity and
and try to wave through um sort of all
the
all the mess that's happening right now
so so hopefully it's a really exciting
year in particular
to to really be innovating in the arts
thank you all right um
i could probably talk to you for 16 more
years about
ovid innovation in the arts but that's
not why we're here tonight um
if anybody has any other questions i
would like to
you know encourage that and if not um
you know thank you so much carly this
was really fantastic
great conversation great presentation um
i really appreciate your being here and
thank you to everybody else who came
really great questions very engaging
this was a delight
yeah thank you guys this is really fun
and thanks for all the great questions